[Musique]
noël sans joie c'est ce que laissent
présager les cabanes déserté du célèbre
marché de noël deviennent les cas de
kovy 19 flambe en autriche et donc les
lumières festive s'éteignent pour au
moins trois semaines
depuis ce matin les échoppes qui propose
artisanat produits du terroir et autres
plaisirs ont dû comme la plupart des
commerces du pays fermé leurs volets
anna travaille ici depuis une douzaine
d'années elle comprend le confinement
soit de nouveau nécessaire mais elle en
veut à ceux qui refusent encore de se
faire vacciner xmp chamanique alès je ne
pense pas qu'on doit forcément faire
tout ce qui est ordonnée par les
politiciens dit elle mais il faut
assumer un peu de responsabilité
la plupart des gens croient que le corps
un avis ruche va disparaître d'un coup
comme ça mais ce n'est pas le cas je
pense qu'il faut faire preuve de
responsabilité
en annonçant la fermeture forcée des
restaurants des boutiques et des lieux
de loisirs le gouvernement s'en est
aussi pris à un tabou pour bien des
dirigeants européens
la vaccination obligatoire pour tous
le parlement devrait adopter
prochainement une loi pour forcer tous
les autrichiens se faire vacciner avant
le 1er février prochain
katarina est venu pour une première dose
du vaccin father à contrecoeur se
méfiant toujours des vaccins de type arn
ministre ne quitte à fond de votre sac
je ne suis pas vraiment convaincu de
recevoir un vaccin est reine dit elle je
ne sais pas si c'est une bonne chose
mais je me suis résigné en fait c'est la
vérité
elle gaz cinq ans est tout aussi
contrariés et sa mère est soulagés
qu'elle puisse elle aussi recevoir la
protection dont tout son entourage
bénéficie depuis la semaine dernière
l'autriche vaccine les enfants de 5 à 11
ans le suçon qu'elle a reçu en cadeau ne
console pas complètement et le gars qui
devra revenir pour une deuxième dose
dans trois semaines
malheureusement soupire katrina mais
comme pour tous les vaccins qu'elle a
reçu comme il se doit pour les enfants
nous lui expliquons que c'est comme ça
que nous protégeons sa santé et que si
elle devait être malade elle ne le
serait pas grave
si le rebond d'activité dans les centres
de vaccination est une très bonne chose
disent les responsables
l'obligation vaccinale en février
prochain c'est trop tard
ce matin
nous avions rendu la vaccination
obligatoire plutôt partout en europe 17
médecins nous n'aurions peut-être pas de
quatrième vague je crois que nous
empruntons la bonne voie en autriche et
j'espère que l'europe va nous suivre
brooklyn heights et web
les nouvelles mesures sanitaires dérange
surtout à l'extrême droite de
l'échiquier politique qui dénonce une
dictature sanitaires ce samedi quelques
cinquante mille personnes ont défilé
dans les rues de vienne pour exprimer
leur colère et capa des pontons chirico
nous avons en autriche un parti le fp
haut qui s'opposent clairement la
vaccination obligatoire dit cet analyste
qui en fait s'oppose au vaccin c'est un
parti qui recommande par exemple les
vermifuges comme médicaments contre le
virus ou les gens se sont déjà retrouvés
dans les unités de soins intensifs à
cause d'un empoisonnement et ce parti a
entre 20 et 25 pour cent d'appuis chine
soit 6 9% si l'autriche n'a plus le
choix que d'imposer la vaccination le
confinement général d'une population
vaccinée à quelque 66% va trop loin
selon ce député membre du parti le plus
important au parlement
nous pensons c'est trop tôt dit il ce
sont deux provinces en autriche où il y
à de très forts taux de contamination
ils ont fait trop d'erreurs mais ça ne
veut pas dire que tout le pays doit être
confiné
le gouvernement fait tout ce qu'il avait
promis de ne pas faire dit il souhaitant
que cette fois il tiendra parole et que
le confinement sera levé à temps pour
profiter un peu de ce qui restera des
fêtes de fin d'année ici marie ève
bédard radio canada viennent